en 1999 les premiers brevets g font leur
apparition dans les chaînes de
restauration rapide au canada chez
arbitres
vingt ans plus tard on en trouve aussi
chez hays w burger king et coop brunch
grande surprise pour ce qui est des
bains de vg de l'offre restaurant on
n'essaie pas juste de copier le goût la
texture et la couleur on essaie de
copier le profil nutritionnel on dirait
aussi c'est très gras est fichue mansaly
l'an dernier un petit nouveau fait son
apparition le burger beyond mythe
développer en californie cette galette
100% végétale ressemble à s'y méprendre
à du boeuf haché qu'est ce qu'on a et si
mac ça c'est bien c'est fait à base de
pois haricots mungo ce riz brun et
plusieurs d'autres choses la betterave
pour donner la couleur de la viande trac
c'est vraiment un bel 2 qui goûte et
ressemble à l'amiante
c'est qui le public cible avos et tous
les consommateurs qui veut manger un
produit le protéines végétales
c'est ce que j'ai de plus en plus de
mignot qui m
vj de luxe c'est impressionnant le goût
du viril l'ensemble je comprends de
source haut placée à se méprendre
mais encore une fois aussi grand et
aussi salée que régulier pas de grandes
mineurs de trucs en particulier gecko
paris pour le plaisir le vg de luxe avec
le diable au kilo de boeuf avec fromage
mozzarella et beckham ou surprise ils
ignorent 75% plus de sodium dans la
version déjà que dans le modèle burger
avec des cannes sort sa mort inverser le
bihan demi et le vg de luxe de a et w
sont les plus à l'est de notre
échantillon
quand on parle de presque mille 400 mg
de sodium on est à 60 % de l'apport
maximal tolérable pour une journée il
n'y a pas de frais tout autre
accompagnement dans tout ça monsieur
grande joie mais le coupable
ce n'est pas tant la galette que les
sauces et les condiments et surprise le
pain le pays est une source de se dire
mais j'ai envie de dire caché est
surprenante dans les idées d'exemple en
fait que j'ai pu trouver de ce qui est
utilisé en restauration on parle entre
350 et 400 mg de sodium qui provient
juste du pain c'est significatif
ici mais la version pro de pain avec la
laitue le fait de remplacer le pen
des feuilles de laitue ont fait retirer
400 mg de soutien mais c'est bon comme
ça
honnêtement la plupart dvg burgers sont
aussi très riche en gras mais
comparativement aux burgers de viande
les vg ont très peu ou pas de gras
saturés et trans
autre élément qu'il faut faire attention
c'est les sauces
tout ce qui est mayonnaise aux sources
crémeuse à jodie nommé le comme vous
voulez sont des sources de matières
grasses vraiment importante
bonjour nous allons prendre des mesures
s'il vous plaît si on met la sauce
barbecue de la maia davies et burger
king offre les options les moins grasse
pour manger si c'était celui pour lequel
le taux de matière grasse était faible
par les valeurs de base qu'on se
trouvait à war iii tn pas très élevé
mais la teneur en protéines est plutôt
faible dans ses galettes ceux qui s'en
sortent le mieux du loup sont les
options entre autres de sw où les
teneurs en protéines aussi autour du 20
grammes ce qui est quand même moins que
pour un burger fait de viande mais qui
est une teneur plus que raisonnable mais
si le vj ben gold harvest qui
l'emportent en termes de protéines passé
seul je crois qu'il est 100% souriant
comme source de protéines davantage du
soyez c'est que ça pour qu'on peut lui
donner la saveur pour eux visiblement
ils ont travaillé avec tous les arômes
habituel du boeuf grillé
vous avez kannberg mais quatre ces trois
pour isabelle pour moi comme un brunch
est une chaîne de restauration rapide
végétalienne né à montréal en 2014
j'aime bien ce que j'ai vu du côté de
koper brunch en termes de variété
d'ingrédients de fraîcheur de créativité
tout ça c'est intéressant
j'en ai essayé quelques uns c'est très
savoureux
par contre beaucoup moins de protéines
mais vraiment le réinventer donc de
portobello complet qui a été aussi c'est
un champignon est très utilisé dans
l'est
végétarien c'est celui de leurs gammes
par contre il contient le moins de
protéines au total
certaines des options à base de riz et
de champignons le c'est sûr que les
teneurs en protéines chute c'est
beaucoup moins nourrissant quand on est
avec ses options blanc le montréalais
rios une fan tino est le fondateur de
cette chaîne qui compte maintenant plus
de 50 succursales au canada aux états
unis et en france
le monde qui vont chez nous utilisons
des poissons sont réussis tahri un
végétalien et la balance et toutes des
mondes qui veut réduire la consommation
de la viande ou être qu'est ce qu'on
appelle flex italienne qui flex entre
les deux et c'est juste pour la santé
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la viande c'est
vraiment à s'y méprendre vraiment rsa
broute là où la galette vigilant porte
sur le burger de boeuf c'est pour sa
teneur en fibres quelques entre autres
de l'offre chic upper hand qui nous fait
un beau mélange non seulement de
protéines végétales mais aussi de toutes
sortes de légumes
donc on se retrouve avec des teneur en
fibres qui vont jusqu'à 50 % de nos
besoins quotidiens sont venus alors dans
ce cas ci c'est un avantage mais ici
aussi comme chez les autres restaurants
le sodium est très élevé dans deux des
quatre buts
il ya certaines banlieues qui
contiennent beaucoup de sodium
un peu plus de sel mais on a fait des
tests des tests est malheureusement le
monde
aussi il aime le cirque vous avez essayé
de réduire puis les gens n'y a pas de
goût le monde malheureusement des fois
il soit fait de manger pour varier votre
menu ou par conviction
les vg burger peuvent être une option
intéressante mais il ne faut pas
s'imaginer qu'ils sont vraiment plus
santé que leurs équivalents carnet